Trouble in paradise.
Welcome to Unfiltered. I'm S.E. Cupp.
What once seemed like
a Republican Party
united around
former President Donald Trump
now seems more like a house divided.
And as Lincoln said,
a house divided against itself
cannot stand.
Since Trump announced his run
for president in 20, 24.
You would have expected Trump World
to be completely re-energized
and coalesced
around their one time savior.
But not so much.
Steve Bannon, the former
architect of Trump's first campaign
and a chief strategist, hasn't been shy
about criticizing Trump's moves
since then.
After Trump released a much mocked NFT,
Bannon took to his podcast to say,
I can't do this anymore.
And called
for whoever was behind that decision
to be fired.
I, for one, have to assume
Trump himself was behind that decision.
And this week, Trump announced
he would appear with South
Carolina Senator Lindsey Graham
in that state
to reveal key campaign staff.
Bannon did not take that news
well either, saying,
I have no earthly idea
why Graham's around
former President Trump.
He's a cancer that's metastasizing
This follows another two key
supporters of Trump.
The evangelical pastors, Franklin
Graham and Robert Jeffress,
both saying
they wouldn't endorse Trump
or any candidate
until after the primaries.
Trump railed against that decision,
calling it a sign of disloyalty.
And Trump's former press secretary,
the new governor of Arkansas,
Sarah Huckabee Sanders,
has also refused to endorse him
right now for 20, 24
Now, the Republican on Republican crime
doesn't stop there, though hardly over.
The RNC current chair, Ronna McDaniel
is in a bitter race against former
Trump lawyer Harmeet Dhillon
and Mypillow CEO Mike Lindell
to keep her position and the food fight
among these three
Republican Trump supporters
has not been pretty.
Former Secretary of State
Mike Pompeo,
also mulling a run for president,
has broken with Trump to defend more aid
to Ukraine
to defeat President Vladimir Putin there.
Incidentally, Pompeo is also fighting
with former U.S.
ambassador to the U.N., Nikki Haley.
Another possible presidential candidate
over some comments
he made about her in his book.
Over in the House, Representative
Marjorie Taylor Greene
and Representative Matt Gaetz
are engaged in a petty fight over
who is the leading
MAGA voice in Congress.
Now, lest
you think this is all bad news for Trump,
I actually have the opposite concern.
With so many Republicans
contemplating a run in 20, 24.
Pompeo. Haley. Mike Pence.
Ron DeSantis. John Bolton.
No one is poised to actually give him
a real challenge
He'll be a weaker
candidate than he was in 20, 16 and 20.
20, for sure.
But he only needs a plurality
to win the nomination.
The infighting inside Trumpworld, RNC
and in the Republican House
will only be good for Trump
as he'll weaponize it to reward loyalty.
This is
however, very bad
news for the Republican Party.
Another two years of jockeying
for Trump's affection
and a likely Trump nomination
will continue
to do
what it has been for the past six years,
weakening the GOP
to the point of utter uselessness.
That's it for me. See you next week.